А я майстерню мав там у Дубовому гаї,
зробив інтер’єр там, люстри, усяке оформлення,
і мені директор дав майстерню там таку маленьку,
я з ними мав часто ходити в гори.
Але все з інструментом і будував це.
А він мав вести людей, він такий, з гумором.
Та він каже (а то все я зробив з дерева):
то Янко Дерев’яний.
І з того стало народне звання.
Отак і вийшло. З його легкої руки.
Для мене просто є вчителі Гауді, Калатрава.
Калатрава, ви знаєте, то такий,
що мости робить, іспанець.
Ну а Гауді він же ж чистий біонік.
Ви заходите на наші буки,
шкода, що нема часу, пішли би.
Тут є така, її назвали со-церква.
Дев'ять таких буків, великим кругом,
заходите всередину і молитесь.
Гауді все брав з природи.
У нього все, отут росте блекота,
у нього все від блекоти взято.
Це той хрест італійський.
А це те, що по Італії ходили, книжечки.
Бачите яка зйомка.
А то мені ще дома поробили.
Три метри має, дванадцять років я з ним тягався,
з майстрами і майстернями.
Мав три майстерні в Ужгороді.
А за місяці чотири вирізав.
Басано, Італія, там, де Челентано недалеко живе.
Була така маленька церквушка,
вони якусь сучасну добудували.
І там онук Бокшая вітражі робив.
А це старовинна хата була така,
драбина як пружина,
така, що на одній стерні крутиться.
А це у Голандію пішла.
Це величезна розета — була велика композиція.
Це я при радянській владі різав, а таке не можна було.
А мене за таке, як кажуть,
в художньому фонді різали. Таке не можна.
Оцей павук, він був головний, по обидві боки від нього шести.
Цей павук розбився [між ними] і він вже стоїть —
і від нього так набиралися.
Це тераса така. Десь 20 метрів.
Я з бетоном познайомився в армії, бо ми мали диплом — монтажника бетонних конструкцій,
там я закінчив спеціальну практику,
бо там було дуже складно.
Я там побачив справжній бетон,
справжню роботу, бо завод був феноменальний.
А сама електростанція…
Там назброєвий метал, а той завод,
де ми були, там усе вже на космос робили.
Син коваль, а донька економіст,
але малює дуже складну графіку.
То цікаво подивитися.
Зараз вона робить 92 психологічні карти,
мала у Києві маленьку виставку, то їй замовили.
Бо вона художник емоцій, а не професіонал.
А це я в молодості.
1954 рік.
А це італійська… знайома.
[сміються]
Що смієтеся? Життя є життя.
А тут, де алея, тої, що вже нема, то якраз там,
де заїжджаєте наверх і тут збоку, є стара турбаза.
І така гарна туристка була.
То я завжди так ходив — у білій сорочці і у ремені.
То унти вертольотні і ногавиці з овечої шерсті,
вони такі, що в них не змерзнеш.
То мій юний коваль. Тут такі зими були ще недавно,
десь три роки тому. Більше такого не буде.
Тут був сніг такий,
що собака в вікна другого поверху заходила,
а кінь взагалі не виходив… А тепер що.
Я недавно бачив дикого кота.
Перший раз у житті таке бачив.
Хоча з оленем був так чотири кроки.
По молодості було, мені було років 12-14, може 15.
І він вибігає, так і навпроти мене стає,
там така бокова тропа.
Я тоді бачив, як олень кладе роги на спину,
і такі чотири стрибки — і його нема.
Все тріщить, а очі в нього дивляться збоку.
Я то насправді бачив.
І бачив любовну гру цапка і косулі, коли цапок
стає на коліна, і так головою по землі і просить.
І він так навколо неї пів години дивився.
Кабанів є багато.
Там, де вода в нас у Нижньому, там постійно.
Це найбільш мисливське місто.
[грає на музичному інструменті]
Була компанія: 8 французів, француженка,
там був Вальтер такий, бразилієць.
Він поставив мені таке цікаве питання,
от ходили по тих балках, ще навіть не було покрито,
то вже вони мені помогли.
І каже: «Іван, що в тебе найважче в роботі з деревом?»
Більше ніхто так не знає. А то якраз вийшло,
що і робити не можна було, бо то незаконно.
А я кажу: «Знаєш, що у роботі з деревом мені найлегше,
а добратись до неї – найважче».
Як з хрестом було, зі всіма роботами,
ніколи не було червоної доріжки.